how you doing today sir i'm doing okay
i just want i just want to start with a
sincere thank you for all the
entertainment you've done uh you i've
really loved it and i just want to say
thank you thank you very thank you very
much
um so
i'm going to try to ask you a few
questions you haven't been asked uh the
first one is as a fan of the sopranos uh
are there any plans of releasing it in
4k
not that i know of
okay
i was wondering if you were looking out
look to someone on the side being like
is it coming to forecast but anyway um
so was obviously listen i really enjoyed
this movie but it's so rich with
characters and the world that you
explored did you ever think about it as
doing a prequel series or was it always
from the get-go gonna be a movie it was
always gonna be a movie
doing a prequel series had and has no
no attraction to me
it's always going to be
um the one thing about this uh
obviously the editing room is where it
all comes together it's the final
rewrite um can you talk about some of
the bigger challenges you faced once you
got in the editing room with all the
story lines you wanted to portray and
put on the screen
there were some problems
with the first act kind of people were
confused
by the plot which isn't that complicated
but apparently
it was difficult
for people to figure out whether what
they're supposed to be doing following
the story or saying oh look there's
[ __ ] oh there's sylvia so that got they
those two things got in each other's way
that was a problem
uh did you end up with a lot of deleted
scenes in in the in the film have you
had any sort of conversations about
doing an extended cut or this is the
final release isn't it
and how that yeah we
chucked a lot of stuff overboard yeah
is it something that you like well do
you think it'll be shown at some point
do you like releasing that kind of stuff
no
i don't particularly know
got it uh as a fan of this film and
obviously the sopranos um have you had
serious thoughts about doing another a
sequel to this film or is it not
something that interests you
it interests me under certain conditions
um
i know you know who terence winter is
okay if he and i were to do something
like that together that would be that
would be
a
pleasurable and fun and that would be
worth doing
so basically i just need to convince
terrence to come on board and then i
will get another movie maybe that's
correct except he's already he's already
convinced so
um
we have to see what um
[Music]
people with the money have to say
i i it needs to i understand we will
find out a lot more on october 1st
there you go
right
i already got a wrap i'm just going to
i'll stop there and i'm just going to
say seriously thank you so much for
letting me talk to you today and i
really hope it's a huge hit and anything
i can do to help please let me know well
that's very generous thank you very much
you